Our last speaker for today is Mark
Storman and he is the chief operating
officer for
nutrient. Uh Mark came to this position
as an outgrowth of his experience with
with developing and building CG systems.
Right. Wow. Anorobic digestion CG
at Fair Oaks. at Ferros and he's
continuing in that view. Yeah, it's a
new new name today, but he's he's dealt
with a lot of other renewable energy
industry types of things and he's been
working on that for the last 35 years.
So, with that, I'm going to turn it over
to give give control to
Mark. Thanks, Jeff.
I want to just touch on a little bit of
the question because one of the things
that we're really working on is at
nutrient is product orientation. You
know, you're the question that was asked
of Jeff is what's important, you know,
the operating cost or the the what's
really important is the net cost. And if
we can't create products that drive
projects that make product but makes a
make a profit, we just won't have
projects. We're just they're not going
to happen. And that's what we see over
and over again. So, uh, nutrient was was
formed because we have this dilemma.
You've all heard the joke. Two little
twins, one's a optimist, one's a
pessimist. Well, that's where we're at,
right? Take him to a psychiatrist.
Psychiatrist takes the one kid, puts him
in a room full of horsemen, closes the
door. That'll take care of his optimism.
Takes the other young man, puts him in a
room full of toys, and the kid sits
right down and starts crying. And he's
like,"Wh are you crying?" And the young
man says, "Because I know sooner or
later you're going to take all these
toys away from me." The psychiatrist
goes, "I can't believe this." Well, at
least this other young man cannot have
found a positive in that room full of
horse manure. So, he goes to the room
full of horse manure. He opens the door
and the kid is having a ball. He is
throwing manure everywhere. And the
psychiatrist
goes, "Why are you so happy?" and he's
like, "If there's this much horse
manure, there's got to be a pony in here
somewhere." Well, this is kind of the
situation we're in in the animal
agriculture neighborhood. You've got
optimists and you've got
pessimists. And nutrient is kind of
formed to help optimists be a little bit
more realistic, shall we say, and
pessimists to be a little less negative,
if we can. We were actually formed by uh
an group of dairy cooperatives. DMI is
this this group above the line
represents about 50% of the milk in the
United States and 50% of the cows. Uh
DMI and National Milk represent
certainly a larger group and they both
are on our board. And the idea behind it
was that the dairy industry didn't
really have an environmental management
group that took care of the third M on
the dairy, the back end of the dairy. Um
we currently see that we have increased
regulatory pressure, increased
environmental issues, increased societal
pressure on our producers. But what we'd
like to see is that we would be solving
those issues that we would realize
economic benefits for solving those
issues and that we would become the
producers of choice. Now that doesn't
mean we don't want other but we would
like people to say I wish everybody
would do it like the dairy community
does and that's what we're trying to
work toward and we're trying to work
toward products products that lead to
incentivized projects that increase the
profits for the dairy mill long-term it
comes down to sustainability is all
about staying in
business. That was a definition that
wasn't listed, but it's all about
staying in business. And so what we've
done is we've asked the question, what
technologies are out there to produce
products? And so we as nutrient were
only formed about 2 years ago, but we
started out by saying, what technologies
are out there? So we were launched in
July of 2015. We formed a technology
team. Um there's there's more of us now
than this select group. And we set out
with the goal to evaluate what
technologies are out there and how can
we put vendors and technologies together
with dairy farms that need this
technology and how can we help
incentivize both. And so we had to
actually go through a couple iterations.
We we actually launched a SharePoint
site to work internally to be able to
work on our documents. and we we built
out our first edition of our catalog on
that SharePoint site. Um it turned out
to be really too big and too robust like
everything everything grows to fit the
space. So we actually transitioned after
we launched our website to a a computer
system called Sitecore and then we
launched our beta version to our board
in November and December and in March
1st we actually launched the nutrient
catalog. If you go to nutrient.com and
it says catalog up there, you can go to
the nutrient catalog right now. So don't
everybody pull it up on their phones.
We're going to stay with the slides, but
afterwards I'll show you what we're
doing. So what did we do to evaluate
technologies? How how do you how do you
go about looking at everything from
anorobic digesttors to slope screens to
generators to CNG stations and things
like that? Well, the first thing we said
is let's let's catalog the technologies
and then let's ask them what their
business is like. So, we created a
business information request and then we
said, okay, that's your business, but do
you have specific technologies that you
sell in your business? And I'm going to
pick on a couple of different different
technology providers. Car's in the room,
so I'll pick on him a little bit because
he deserves it. And then there's other
guys out there. There are people that
sell multiple technologies. As a matter
of fact, car's technology breaks down
into two or three different
technologies. So you might have two or
three different pages in the catalog.
You would use the same business
information. It's not doesn't change his
business, but it does change the
technology and and that's how we make
the information available to people. And
then we wanted to do on-site visits for
those technologies that showed real
promise. We wanted to create a
standardized case study where the
nutrient technology people would go to
the vendor and say, "Take us to your
site. Take us to somewhere where you can
say, "This is it. This it doesn't get
much better than this if you put that
in." Now, I had an advantage. Car's
Carrie's system at at Fair Oaks is 20
minutes from my house. So, I've been to
his site multiple times and I helped
build the site, but we had an
opportunity to walk through there and
look at it and to talk to people and to
do an evaluation. And then we wrote up a
case study and then we shared that case
study and went back and forth so we
could really document what's happening
there when this works, right? And then
finally, we compiled all this
information, assessed it, and
synthesized it and put it into the
catalog. But then we decided to go one
step further because it's it's one thing
to have a catalog. It's another thing to
actually have information that goes
beyond the catalog. And so what that
team of experts that I showed you on the
first page was is we tried to use a
criteria scale to help make informed
decisions and to make recommendations
about technologies. And and so we
created the nine-point scoring system.
And then we actually created a couple of
different categories to recognize
technologies. And when we say rig
recognized technologies or we we
consider it a technology an emerging
technology, here's the criteria that we
use. Two farmers walk out of the coffee
shop, they walk out, they get to the
front of their truck, and one farmer
says, "Hey, I heard you bought name the
technology." and they lean for five
minutes on the front of somebody's
pickup truck and they talk about that
technology. That's what we're trying to
do. We're not trying to say, "Oh, this
is the technology you have to buy."
We're trying to say, "This is
information you'd like to know about
this
technology." If we're saying it's
emerging, it's probably something you
want to talk a little more about. This
is worth looking at. If it's recognized,
it's probably established. there's
probably a reason that it got to where
it is, but and you should probably
consider this if you're going to put in
that type of system. So certainly if you
have no reason to do clear
water, then you don't want to go to the
nutrient recognized technologies that
produce clean water because you're
unless of course you're just so cash
you'd like to invest in things and try
them. But we're trying to say if you're
going to put in something to get clean
water, then if there's a nutrient
recognized vendor, you should consider
talking to them as part of your
research. So that was the idea behind
the catalog. The nine-point criteria was
actually grew out of a lot of struggle
within our group. Our technology
advancement team, part of us wanted to
just really have numbers like we want to
put everybody's numbers right out there.
But then you have such divergent
technologies that what does a number
mean? I mean, and then another part of
us said, well, let's just be subjective.
Let's just put comments out there. We
didn't really like that either. So, what
we ended up doing was we came up with
this nine-point system. And you can see
they're kind of divided into three
groups. The first group was about
commercial viability. Do you have an
operational history? Do you have third
three systems operating on a dairy farm?
If you do, that goes from white to
brown. Do you have a record of 12 months
of reliability on those three? Another
another point, market penetration. Once
you get 10, you get the third one. And
you can see how it works. Have you in
that business and economic transparency
um technology, have you really explain
what your capex is or is it to be
determined by site? Right?
And we all know that there are
technologies that the price of the
technology depends on who they are
talking to, right?
So we try to get as much quantifiable as
we can in those TIS and BIS. We every
everybody's got acronyms, right?
Business information request, BIR,
technology information request,
TIR, operation and maintenance cost. And
then
um we actually switched these around
because we did we wanted this value
proposition with the economics. But the
value proposition doesn't have to
necessarily be
dollars. It's value to the farm. And
I'll give you Fair Oaks is a great
example. When I first started working
for Fair Oaks, there wasn't a single
dig. There were nine dairy farms. Almost
not drive down I65. The smell was so
bad. And people weren't liking it. Local
people were upset. Over the next five
years, every digtor near the highway put
in an anorobic digesttor. 100% almost
30,000 cows going into anorobic
digesttor. You didn't smell
it. If we had tried to build a tent farm
without those digesttors, we' have never
got a permit. County wouldn't have
issued it. We had had
riots. Now we built a visitor center,
actually four visitor centers, and a
half a million people a year visit the
Fair Oaks Farms agurism
site. Completely different
situation. Did did the
digesttors add value? Absolutely. Can
you quantitize the odor reduction value?
No. we were able to expand. We were able
to build other businesses around it. And
then finally, real quickly, those um
vendor information sharing and business
technology information, those case
studies I referred to. And then the last
part is through constant contact, we
actually allow the vendors to reach out
to their customers, to the people
they've sold systems to and ask for a
rating. And the rating is very simple.
On a scale of 1 to 10, would you
recommend this technology to another
farmer? And why? That's it. You get over
seven from three of your vendors, you
get that last
point. So, this is a mockup of the
catalog real quickly because every time
I go out and do this, I try to do it
online, right, to actually show you the
catalog and every time there's a
technical D. So, I doing this on the
slide and then I actually have it pulled
up and it's working on Google. So, if
you want to look at it live, we can do
that afterwards. But basically the first
thing you do is you sign on to the
technology and it gives you an
explanation of how the thing works and
it gives you criteria that you may want
to use. And when you say you type in
tried it or you click on nutrient
recognized technologies it would fill in
here in what we call the landing page
all of the technologies that met your
criteria. So you can do very in-depth
searches there or you can just hit I
want to see all technologies and it pops
up 17 pages and 178 some technologies.
Right now when you click on the
individual pages you go to the
technology page and I'm going to
actually get a little bit more into
that. This is what happened when we um
taking it for a test drive when I put in
the category nutrient recognized. These
are the two that popped up right now.
Part of that is because we're still in
the process of getting a lot of the
material done. So this is the DVO what
we all have come to know as mixed
complete mixed digtor or mixed plug flow
digtor. And this is the mlina hand sand
separators. Two established technologies
lots of history. You know those were
done fairly early on because we did a
lot of testing with them. I could have
also clicked on emerging technologies in
Udys and carry system there and also a
couple of other systems. You've heard of
the Vanguard business model. That's
another one. But here is where you you'd
click on one of these and then you'd
move on. And I just happen to use the
Mlanahan sand separation because it
didn't really apply as much to the
individual. So we can talk about the
website, not the technology. But there's
the company description. the company
description, all of this information on
this half of the page. Nutrient through
the technology team and the leadership
they provide works to develop all of
this information with the vendor. So
there's a brief company description, a
picture of the technology, a description
of the technology, all of their contact
information, if they've got a YouTube
site, a LinkedIn site, a Facebook site,
everything they might want to put there.
These are the categories that they fall
in. And then business information,
equipment insights, photo links, video
links, case studies, all go right
here below the
fold. This is our little box for the
lawyers, the legal disclaimer that says
all of the things that anyone says a
lot. It basically says that we got this
from public information. We're not going
to defame anybody and stuff like that.
Below the line, we have basic
information. If there is a if it's a
standard system for say slope screens or
solid separation, there might be a
little description of what the big
process
does. And then there's actually
specifics to let you know and understand
what the technology advancement team
understands about that technology. And
then you can real quickly look at this.
And of course with a pointer it's not
moused over but when you mouse over it
it actually explains to you which of
these categories are you click in the
center of that score you end up knowing
what the final is what it'll take you to
a page where it explains
everything. I'm going to share with you
that we're actually continuing to work
on this. This is a suspended solid. So
here's that little kind of table of what
the technology is like. We're kind of
working on a way
to add a add a criteria at the
technology level that would help people
see how these would perform on your
farm. So for example, you would have N
recovery, P recovery, greenhouse gas
reduction, storage reduction, odor
reduction, and pathogen reduction. How
does this perform to the baseline for a
flush dairy, a dry lot dairy, or a
scrape dairy? And so that a farmer could
very quickly see, oh that that I'm a
flush. That's not going to do anything
for me. Now, I just made that up. These
are just mocked up because we haven't
gotten through that process. That's a
process we're working on to take it to
the next
level. Questions?
How much does it cost for a vendor to be
out there? Nothing. How much does it
cost for a producer to go there?
Nothing. They do have to put in their
name and their email address. So, how do
you pay for all this? We are funded out
of a very small check off portion from
those 12 dairy cooperatives and some
money from DMI. And and this portion,
just so that people kind of understand,
DMI is checkoff dollars. This portion
primarily is checkoff dollars because
it's all pre-ompetitive. It's all done
on a very non-competitive. We're just
evaluating technologies that are out
there basis.
Jordan, uh, do you when you like when
you get numbers the pathogen removal and
things like that, how where do those
numbers come from? What we're what we're
in the process of doing right now is
having those discussions. The idea is
that we would start by quantifying
what's out there in peer-reviewed
literature, what's out there in
thirdparty validated literature, and
then we'll probably end up going to ex
putting together a room full of people
like this to get expert opinion for
those missing gaps. But that process is
actually we launched this in March. So
that's kind of the discussion around
version 2.0. That probably won't happen
till next year sometime. That I mean
that would seem quite expensive as the
trouble coordinators always have with
creating paintings is
it is it is quite expensive and and part
of the reason that we can do this is we
have distributed and work with a lot of
consultants. We don't have a lot of
full-time employees but we do try to get
a lot accomplished. So let's go to Bill
and then we'll get Jeremy. So, uh, you
heard Jeff say that the producer wants
to go to capital cost. Um, in your in
your model, your online form is for
Mlanahan, for example, is there
something in there that that gives you
cost for we ask we ask specifically if
they have if in the technical
information, if you click on that,
you'll download a PDF. It's 17 pages
long. It asks things like what kind of
water connection do you need? what kind
of power connection do you need? And it
asks specifically, what is the capital
cost of this equipment? And is it
scalable? So, for instance, somebody
might say, our system for 1,000 cows is
$500,000. I'm just making up numbers
right now. And it's scalable up, but not
down. This is as small as we make it.
So, again, it depends on the technology.
And that's why we've we've talked about
in this in this model having some sort
of
quantifiable, you know, idea of what the
impact is. We've actually even talked
about on the outside edges putting in
capital cost and operating cost and just
doing something like you see in a
restaurant of $1 sign to $4 signs. But
you know, it's very difficult to do
because something might be a very high
capital cost but very low operating cost
and that might work fine for somebody
because it's so it's a one-time
commitment and I can get a equip grant
to help cover the cost. I'll put it in.
So it that becomes really tricky when
you start dealing with relative cost of
technologies from anorobic digestion
down to a slope screen. Yeah, that was
another Yeah, let's go to Jeremy. Um
well this might be pretty quick. Um so
you mentioned like 178 so far in there.
It looks like I'm assuming these are all
onfarm systems or are there dairy based
technologies that would be centralized
or mobile that work across multiple
operations? There are a few centralized
and mobile systems. This this is
actually because it did work. This is
the actual page. So you can see here's
how it works and those sort of things.
And what I'm going to do just
to what I'm going to do if I can get the
mouse to work for me is I I'll just
quickly take you to the
uh all technology so you see how it pops
up. So you get about 10 10 pages if if
we haven't been able to validate the
information on the top page. So we build
these websites out of the publicly
available information, but we do put a
signal on it if it's not validated yet.
So like makes a gas upgrading system. So
but we haven't been able to get a hold
of them to validate all the numbers and
and the information that's there and get
a BIR and TI. So we just put that as a
flag up there. It's there's nothing
wrong with it. It's just we're still in
the process of working on it. But
there's about 17 pages like that. Got
two questions and we're going to have to
wrap it up. So Mark, but I'm willing to
stay and if you want to see stuff, we'll
play with it. But you guys are all free
to go after the next two. These two
questions. Just to follow up on the on
the cost in and and maybe uh on that
where you're where you're going back and
making some judgment calls on that. Is
there going to be an opportunity to then
to for your ex your panel or experts or
whatever to say is that a realistic
cost? Because if if the technology
provider they're giving a c cost for the
piece of equipment, they're not
necessarily going to be saying what's it
going to cost to retrofit that into your
existing system. So we we definitely
again remember the goal is you're
leaning on your pickup truck. Should I
call this vendor or not? So we're not
trying to replace any vendor. I mean if
you ask me should I call them?
Absolutely you should. But what I'm
trying to do is help guide you in a
direction. And so, you know, if if it
looks to us like there may have been
issues with a technology, then as
politely as we can without saying don't
call these people, we say make sure you
ask about reliability. You know, have
this discussion with the vendor, right?
So, and your idea what's too high a cost
and my idea might be different. And so
we're just trying to get the information
out there. We're trying to be very fair
to the vendors and the people who are
providing the technologies. At the same
time, we're probably trying to add value
to the dairy farmer who may be looking
at these technologies.
Nick, do you evaluate um only US
companies or is it other? What we've
done, and there's a few exceptions in
here, but what we've done is we've only
looked at US dairy installations. Now,
there are a few companies that have
joined with us that seem to have good
technologies that have promised for use
in the United States that have not yet
been able to find someone. What happens
in those cases is we'll put in the
comments that this has not been
evaluated using the nine-point system
because it's not operational on a dairy,
but the technology looks like it could
work. So until you actually have
something on a dairy, we're not going to
do an evaluation because even though it
even though you have 10 of them in
Italy, I'm not familiar with the I mean,
I'd love to go and spend a few weeks
studying the dairy practices of Italy,
don't get me wrong, but I'm not familiar
enough with it to say that that's going
to be transferable.
Does that make sense? Let's give it We
might close it off from there.